hey youtubers is Charlie huge news we
actually have some season 7 footage so
this is like a really short HBO trailer
I'm going to loop it a couple times
because it's so short in its super janky
so hopefully HBO will post a high-res
version real soon but here it is
so we have John Sansa in Arya and it
looks like John and Sansa are at
Winterfell here I have some better
pictures of this that are a little bit
better resolution so you almost wouldn't
know that this is footage from season 7
if they didn't tell you in that HBO
trailer so they kind of did this last
year then they started releasing brand
teasers and stuff so I would expect
little things like this to start
dropping through the rest of the year
even though Game of Thrones isn't gonna
premiere till the middle of next year
like wait later than April like late
June early July they'll still be
dropping stuff like this don't want to
get people hyped up so they'll still be
Game of Thrones Season 7 things
happening throughout the year but we
actually learned some cool stuff from
this so if you look at John he's wearing
the same outfit he was at the end of
season six it's almost dead on for the
same outfit that Robb Stark was wearing
before he died so like all the Star
children are starting to look and dress
like their parents like Robin started to
look like Ned Stark a little bit this
Sansa image is even more telling
she's wearing a Catelyn Stark wig so if
you're wondering why she's wearing the
wig is because she dyed her hair blond
in real life for whatever reason for
whatever other project she's working on
but Sansa needs to have red hair now
it's just looking more and more like
catlins hair so she's slowly becoming
her mother but Arya is a little harder
to parts like she's on a horse so it's
hard to tell where she is she was last
at the twins down here so it looks like
she's headed north maybe she makes her
way up to Winterfell this is kind of
like a stark teaser trailer so it would
seem to imply because Jon and sanso are
at Winterfell on this that Arya would
make her way up there eventually but the
thing is is that they're all so
different from where they were the last
time they were all together which is way
back in season 1 that's how long it's
been like George are Martin said that
when the story starts out everyone
starts in the same place then as the
story gets on it slowly pulls them all
in different directions and as you reach
the end of the story they all start to
converge again so now that we're hitting
winds of winter in the books we're
hitting the last couple of seasons
everyone has started to converge again
and even though there are a bunch of
characters on game of throne
they largely framed that first season as
Starks versus Lannister's so it seems
like we might be going back to that just
a little bit but the thing is is that
they've been gone for so long they've
changed so much I wouldn't assume that
they're all going to be super best
friends when they get back together
there's already problems between Sansa
and John right now the character that it
looks like he's talking to on the
battlements of Winterfell here looks
like Santa so this is all probably from
that first episode they've been shooting
for a while but there's still like a
couple of the big action set pieces that
they're filming right now we don't
really need to talk about them I know
people aren't really big on spoilers and
it's still really really early so we can
talk about that stuff later on it's just
that you always expect them to echo the
big tent poles of each season like
Battle of the bastards in each
successive season so like we add black
water then the red wedding then Watchers
on the wall then the Battle of the
bastards there will be something like
that in the final season and part of the
reason why they had to reduce the
episode count to 7 episodes is because a
lot more of them will be filmed like the
Battle of the bastards episode whole
bunch of people lots of extras lots of
animals like everything cranked up to 11
so it is a bummer that we're not going
to get those extra three episodes but
each of the episodes they are filming
are supposed to make up for that so they
haven't said anything about how long the
episodes are actually going to be but
well past 60 minutes so it'll be
interesting to see if they can clean up
what's happening in and around
Winterfell in the north after the Battle
of the bastards
what Sansa will want to do about her
mother's home Riverrun because it is
almost like the new Harrenhal of the
Riverlands which is kind of funny
because Harrenhal is in the Riverlands
but just look in the map here see how
close they are to the Eyrie Littlefinger
has all those troops so he might be able
to tempt Sansa with freeing Riverrun
from Lannister control then you have the
Brotherhood that's slowly making its way
north to they were last seen near the
salt pans when the Hound joined their
band they told him they were heading
north so it seems like a lot of these
characters are all heading north
so if Arya has a horse it seems like
that reunion will take place at
Winterfell which doesn't say anything
about bran he's nowhere in this teaser
which may be just because they want to
keep it real
short but Ellie Kendrick was talking
about how she still has to haul him
around so they're moving way slower so
it's going to take them way longer to
get to Winterfell if that's where
they're going but they still need to go
to the wall first but you guys can let
me know do you think that all the stark
children will converge at the same time
or if like Arya will make her way to
Winterfell they'll all freak out even
though Sansa knows that she's still
alive
Brienne told her that she saw her before
she went east and then do you think that
bran will come in and explain everything
all the visions that he's had the past
that he's seen the truth of Jon Snow's
parentage the way the showed
disseminates information like that like
the information that bran has usually
gets attached to other really big
moments like you see Jon Snow named king
of the north
just as you find out who his mother
truly is implied who his father is
even though unofficially behind the
scenes HBO confirmed that Rhaegar
Targaryen is his father
you can only wonder what Sato is gonna
say about this when she finds out in
whether or not Littlefinger already
knows or suspects it I don't think that
he does because if he didn't know what
Ramsay was doing to Sansa during season
5 then it doesn't seem like he would
know one of the best-kept secrets in the
history of A Song of Ice and Fire
but Arya has always loved Jon even if
she's a completely different person
inside I feel like they'll have some
common bond like it'll be pretty easy
for them to pick up where they left off
she wasn't too hot on Sansa but she does
love her sister so even if there's some
friction I'm just expecting them to
fight a lot in the way that sisters
would it's just that Arya is a lot more
stabby than she used to be and if you
remember John is the one that gave her
needle so it'll be fun to see her roll
up twice as big with needle on her hip
but bran arriving and telling him
there's so many bigger things they need
to worry about is probably what's going
to keep them from jumping at each
other's throats but you guys can let me
know like what do you feel like the
drama is going to be between the stark
children and why you guys are thinking
about that I'm actually going to be
doing some epic fight night videos like
Arya versus the mountain just like epic
battles in Game of Thrones even if they
haven't happened in the books so be sure
to subscribe to get that and there is a
new round of the giveaway all you have
to do to enter just be a subscriber
leave a comment
on this video but make sure if you are
subscribed that you turn alerts on just
because YouTube has been messing around
with the placement of everything so a
lot more Game of Thrones coming and then
there's also some Rick and Morty that
I'll be posting this week to I feel like
if you haven't seen it you will
definitely be down for it but look out
for some Rick and Morty dropping on my
channel this week - in addition to more
Game of Thrones where you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for like
my top 10 crazy theories and you can
click here for my west world episode 9
episode 10 trailer video thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you